روسيا تنوي نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا
اعصار ميسيسيبي في امريكا خلف عشارات
القتلى
ضغوط على داخل حزبه لتعليق التعديلات
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في اخر فصول التصائده والتهديدات بين
روسيا والغرب عاد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمي
بوتين الى تلويح بالسلاح النووي بعد
اعلانه عزم بلاده نشره اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا اوضح ان ارساله تلك
الاسلحه الى منسك لن ينتهك اتفاقيات عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه مضيفا ان الخطوه
تاتي في اطار اعاده التموضع كما فعلت
امريكا في اوروبا فيما قالت واشنطن من
خطوره بل قللت من خطوره الخطوه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
25 قتيلا على الاقل وعشرات المصابين خلفهم
اعصار مدمر اجتاح ولايه ميسيسيبي
الامريكيه ما دفع بالرئيس جو بايدن الى
اعلان حاله الطوارئ في الولايه في الواقعه
جنوب الولايات المتحده الاعصار القوي ذمر
العديد من القرى والمناطق الريفيه وتسبب
في سقوط الاشجار وقطع خطوط الطاقه فيما
تستعد عده ولايات في امريكا لاحتمال
انتقال الامطار اليها خلال الساعه المقبله
انقسام الحاد يشهده حزب لكود الاسرائيلي
الذي يتزعمه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
ما بين مؤيد ومعارض لوقف تمرير خطه
الانقلاب القضائي التي اثارت جدلا
وانقساما واحتجاجات ضخمه ضد الحكومه
دعا الى اجتماع القاده الاحزاب احزاب
الائتلاف الحاكم فيما اعزز الانشقاق بصفوف
الليكود انضمام
النائب البارز بالكنيسه من الحزب نفسه الى
الدعوه التي اطلقها وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يو اب كلانت لتعليق التعديلات
القضائيه المقترحه
توقيت ثاني مختلفان استيقظ عليهما
اللبنانيون اليوم واستخلافه المتصاعد بين
السلطات السياسيه والتينيه بشان قرار
تمديد العمل بالتوقيت الشتوي لمده شهر
اضافي رئيس حكومه
اصدر قرارا بتاجيل تقديم التوقيت ساعه
واحده الى الشهر المقبل بدلا من عطله
نهايه الاسبوع الاخير من شهر مارس كما جرت
العاده الامر الذي اثار جدلا واسعا حيث
اعلنت بعض القوى السياسيه رفضها للقرار
نختم من عالم تكنولوجيا حيث يختبر تطبيق
المحادثه الشهير واتساب ميزه جديده تمكن
مستخدم هواتف ايفون من تبادل الرسائل
المرئيه القصيره والتي ستكون مشفره من طرف
الى طرف لضمان الخصوصيه الميزه الجديده
تعمل بنفس طريقه الرسائل الصوتيه باتاحه
رمز الكاميرا بجوار رمز الميكروفون
لالتقاط رساله مكيه ومن المتوقع ان تكون
مده الرسائل
60 ثانيه فقط دون السماح بحوض او اعاده
التوجيه تلك الرسائل
[موسيقى]